frauchen ist marlies tepaß sie und ihr
mischling woodtli ein herz und eine
seele
keine frage dieser hund ist ihr bester
freund
für sie besteht daher kein zweifel sie
will neben ihm auch beerdigt werden
weil er zu mir gehört so eheleute werden
auch begraben nebeneinander warum soll
ich meinen hund nicht mit begraben
werden
ich finde das toll dass es so was gibt
noch nicht ganz so überzeugt von der
sache ist ihr mann der sagt ja immer
mensch ist mensch und tst aber wer weiß
als ich das möchte wird noch den wunsch
aphthen mensch und tier zusammen im grab
der essener friedhof unser hafen ist der
erste in deutschland der das erlaubt
aber die friedhofsbetreiber halten sich
an die strengen vorschriften
es ist so dass die einäscherung von
mensch und tier strikt getrennt so dass
das tier im tierkrematorium der mensch
im human krematorium prämiert wird und
anschließend kann die können beide ohren
zu unserer friedhofsverwaltung übergeben
werden und dann organisieren wir die
gemeinsame beisetzung
die kirchen sind bei dem thema gespalten
eine gemeinsame trauerrede für mensch
und tier kommt für die pfarrer nicht
infrage aber die evangelische kirche
kann sich immerhin die asche eines tiers
als sogenannte grabbeigabe vorstellen
dabei gaben haben wir ganz viel wir
dürfen den blumen und blumen blüten ins
grab
manche menschen werfen briefe ins grab
als abschied an den menschen und den
schal von rot weiss essen oder schalke
04 und so manchem bergmann hier im
ruhrgebiet ist auch schon eine flasche
schnaps mit ball gegeben worden
die katholische kirche hat für
solcherlei rituale verständnis aber
nicht für die gemeinsame bestattung von
menschen und tieren
wenn wir am grab beten und einen
menschen bestatten dann drücken wir auch
die würde dieses menschen auch über den
tod hinaus aus in unseren gebeten und in
unseren texten
daher tun wir uns als katholische kirche
schwer mit einem gedanken tier und
mensch auch bei einer bestattung
gleichzusetzen
für marlies täters sind mensch und tier
geschöpfe gottes das hat sie in der
bibel gelesen und das soll für sie und
ihren mut lee bis ins grab gelten können
uns schon heinz aussuchen obwohl noch
gar nicht hinwollen
die deutschen sind bekannt für ihre
ausgesprochene tierliebe auf rund 150
friedhöfen können hierzulande tiere
beigesetzt werden
die einäscherung eines hundes ist im
bestattungs zentrum tier himmel bei
berlin nicht weniger würde voll als die
eines menschlichen familienmitglieds
etwa 3000 tiere liegen hier begraben die
friedhofs leitung denkt nun auch über
einen gemeinsamen platz für tiere und
menschen nach vielleicht hier unter den
bäumen
offiziell ist das in berlin bisher nicht
möglich nur heimlich
wenn man auf human friedhöfen überall
dort wo heimlich ein kia beigesetzt
worden begraben worden ist nach dem tod
eine kerze anzünden würde hätten wir
sehr helle friedhöfe in deutschland
darum muss man aus der illegalität raus
man muss einen platz schaffen wo auch
der besitzer weiß wenn es mal soweit ist
habe ich hier die möglichkeit mich
zusammen mit meinem familienmitglied
hierbei setzen zu lassen
auch für marlies tepaß gehört ihr hund
schon lange zur familie
sie will ihm ewig verbunden bleiben ich
kaputt machen